bonsoir et bienvenue à tous pour cette
nouvelle saison du 7-8 l'hebdo vous
connaissez est la formule elle n'a pas
changé c'est la même que l'an passé 26
minutes d'information pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
avec notamment un invité fil rouge
voici les titres de ce vendredi 1er
septembre et ce premier jour du mois
marqué par le début des commémorations
de l'aïd el kébir fête religieuse pour
les musulmans à saint quentin en
yvelines
l'abattoir mobile qui permettait de se
procurer un mouton selon les rites
prescrit n'est pas reconduit cette année
alors on court qu'un est notre invité
fil rouge pour cette émission
vice-président du medef yvelines nous
évoquerons évidemment avec lui les
ordonnances sur le code du travail et
les universités d'été du medef qui se
tenait cette semaine à jouy en josas
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité
locale et préparatoire de la rentrée
scolaire et les obsèques du maire de
chevreuse c'était mardi
c'est donc ce week-end que les musulmans
fêtent l'aïd el kébir à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines contrairement
aux années précédentes il n'y aura pas
d' abattoir mobile près de la colline
d'elancourt les élus ont décidé de ne
pas reconduire le dispositif provisoire
en place depuis quatre ans déjà la
communauté musulmane doit ainsi se
déplacer en dehors du département pour
se procurer des moutons les détails avec
miquel et demi d'euros et mélanie poker
c'est une première depuis 2013 il n'y
aura pas d' abattoir mobile cette année
sur ce terrain situé à trappes dans la
zone d'activités desbruyères saint
quentin en yvelines a décidé de ne pas
reconduire l'opération provisoire
l'agglomération havok des nuisances au
niveau du voisinage une charge
financière trop importante sur un
dossier qui coûterait entre 200 milles
et 300000 euros avec les difficultés que
nous connaissons dans la raréfaction des
dotations de l'état
on n'a plus les mêmes moyens alors il
serait assez paradoxal on en arrive
envisager la fermeture d'équipements
publics et que l'on continue à assurer
cette manifestation et cette charge
financière
donc je pense que c'est une réseau de
logique et de bon sens
chaque année près de mille cinq cents
moutons étaient proposés à la vente au
marché au vif pour cette fête religieuse
les animaux étaient ensuite sacrifié
suivant les rites devant les familles
un système qui fonctionnait selon les
associations musulmanes on a connu des
abattages sauvages dans les années 80 90
on a trouvé enfin une solution stable
d'un point de vue sanitaire et
sécuritaire on comprend pas qu'en 2017
une situation aussi intéressante aussi
bien pour les musulmans que pour les
pouvoirs publics puissent s'arrêter
l'abattoir mobile le plus proche se
trouve désormais à dreux à plus de 50 km
pour montrer leur mécontentement le
collectif cam 78 a lancé une pétition
courant août
actuellement on est à 887 signature en
ligne
on a plus d'un millier de signatures
papier qui complètent ceux là dont on
est en tout cas plus de 2000 signatures
au total et on a un texte qui explique
de manière très détaillée l'historique
de l'abattoir et la particularité du
loupé de cette année la communauté
musulmane espère désormais trouver un
compromis avec les élus pour organiser
l'événement à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'année prochaine l actualité de cette
fin de semaine marqué et guy évidemment
par la réforme du code du travail jeudi
le gouvernement a dévoilé le contenu des
ordonnances qui devrait modifier
profondément le monde du travail en
france au total cinq ordonnances 36
mesure et 159 pages pour faire baisser
durablement le chômage selon le souhait
du gouvernement du côté des syndicats en
revanche on estime que c'est la
précarité qui se trouve renforcée par
cette réforme écouter la secrétaire
départementale de la cgt
le fonds l'état d'esprit on le
connaissait et ça va vraiment
diminuer les droits des salariés en tout
cas ceux qui ont encore un certain
nombre parce que la réalité c'est qu'on
a déjà beaucoup de salariés de
travailleurs extrêmement précaires les
contrats aidés les intérimaires on peut
même parler vrai de tous ses
travailleurs
hubert ise auto entrepreneurs va qui
commence à voir les limites de ce statut
qui était vantée comme comme merveilleux
et pour savoir si cette réforme du code
du travail consacre la victoire du
modèle hubert laurent courquin est avec
nous en plateau bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes expert comptable membre du conseil
d'administration de bdo france une
société qui fait notamment de l'audit
pour les pme et vice-président du medef
yvelines alors sonia pour vous avez
entendu l'interview at elle raison est
ce qu'on peut dire quelques heures après
avoir vu ce qu'était ces ordonnances que
c'est le modèle hubert et la précarité
qui sortait vainqueur de ceux de cette
réforme du code du travail
alors évidemment je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord donc aller je m'en doutais un
dicton dit que je m'en doute pour
plusieurs raisons il yad'abord
effectivement ce premier constat c'est
que libé risation il existait avant
justement parce que il y avait un
certain nombre de contraintes
en ce qui concerne les différents
contrats de travail et en particulier
donc le cdi donc au contraire je dirais
que tout le but de ces ordonnances c'est
d'améliorer la communication le dialogue
social entre les employeurs et des
salariés
vous vous dites que s'il y avait eu b
risation de la société était en partie à
cause d'un code du travail trop on peut
tout au moins je peux te ment se poser
la question pourquoi libéralisation
sirotant développer alors qu'il y avait
évidemment déjà donc ces lois
protectrices qui protégeait bien entendu
donc beaucoup les salariés déjà en place
ce qui est important de toute façon le
sait bien c'est l'emploi des jeunes est
ce qu'il faut surtout c'est inciter des
entreprises bien entendu à embrocher
donc des jeunes ce qui est vrai le vrai
sujet qui nous concerne tous
alors pour juste évoqué ce volet de la
précarité je dois vous faire réagir sur
l'une des mesures il y en a 36 dans ces
cinq ordonnances c'est le renouvellement
des cdd note notamment maintenant les
branches pourront négocier chacune le
renouvellement des cdd qui sera possible
de faire
par exemple on prend l'industrie du
textile si les partenaires sociaux se
mettent d'accord on pourra renouveler
par exemple c'est un exemple jusqu'à 7 x
5 x ou trois fois quatre fois le céder
dès aujourd'hui la loi fixe deux fois
est-ce que ça c'est pas une forme de
précarité
on a du mal à imaginer des accords qui
vont plutôt aller à la baisse va être
plutôt une augmentation du
renouvellement de cdd est une forme de
précarité qui s'en sortent sans rentrer
le détailler visuellement de tous les
textes
effectivement je crois qu'il faut voir
là dessus il faut être prudent et il
faut voir bien entendu dans les décrets
d'application avant effets du monde tire
des conclusions par rapport à ça il faut
voir également que ce qui est prévu dans
les ordonnances est également des cdi
par objectifs autre monde a appelé
pendant longtemps les cdi de deux
chantiers de chantier autrement dit qui
existe déjà depuis fort longtemps vous
avez raison dans certaines conventions
collectives incertain
profession de certaines activités et qui
donc est
et pour moi je dirais être favorisée et
donc cherché à se développer donc dans
le cadre évidemment donc de ces
nouvelles ordonnances
d'une manière générale comme vous le
verrez vous l'avez rappelé d'ailleurs
c'est effectivement des éléments qui
vont se faire au niveau des branches
donc je veux dire autrement dit il va y
avoir effectivement un dialogue qui va
se faire
pour savoir suivant l'activité dans
lequel on se trouve
il n'aura pas forcément des cdd qui
seront répétés je veux dire un avis ni
je défends pas tirer de conclusion trop
hâtive par rapport à ça l'idée
d'ailleurs aussi il faut pas perdre de
vue que dans l'esprit effectivement des
ordonnances
il ya le dialogue non seulement au
niveau des branches mais également les
possibilités d'accord donc au niveau des
entreprises et notamment pour les plus
petites entreprises ça c'était une bonne
nouvelle une demande du du patronat
justement sur l'ensemble des mesures
dans les grandes lignes on n'a pas
forcément le temps de ce fait évoqué il
ya le barème des indemnités aux eaux
pour les prud'hommes s'il ya la
négociation du coup direct avec les
salariés dans les petites entreprises la
fusion des instances aussi
représentatives du personnel ou encore
le rétrécissement du périmètre pour le
licenciement économique en france selon
vous quelle est là la meilleure réforme
là dedans la meilleure à la meilleure
nouvelle pour les entreprises c'est là
qu'était vraiment essentiel et qui est
maintenant d'accord sur la table
ok là là la meilleure réforme pour moi
c'est le fait qu'une possibilité de
dialogue direct avec les salariés dans
les tpe et dans les pme voudra y est
souvent avec les pme d'ailleurs tout à
fait tout à fait et il faut voir
d'ailleurs que dans toutes les
entreprises jusqu'à 50 salariés à
propres en est physiquement ce seuil
sachant que ce soit continuer d'exister
quand même un en définitive ce qui est
peut-être un petit peu dommage mais
enfin ça c'est comme ça et de toute
façon il ya déjà le seuil est limitée à
50 salariés 50 salariés
le média vidéo est plutôt pour 300
salariés ouais voilà c'est ça mais ce
qui est important surtout c'est que
jusqu'à 50 salariés maintenant il ya des
possibilités effectivement de référendum
et de dialogue direct avec les salariés
alors qu'avant je rappelle c'était la
branche qui s'appliquait pour toutes les
petites entreprises il faut pas oublier
que ça représente 95% des entreprises en
france plus de 55 % des salariés sont
employés dans tout ce type d'entreprises
de tailles d'entreprises
et les syndicats ne sont pas présents
très très peu présents pour diverses
raisons
peu importe ce n'est pas le propos ça
veut donc dire que les ordonnances
permet justement d'instaurer un dialogue
et un référendum c'est une consultation
directe auprès des salariés et de
pouvoir avancer dans les calibres à paul
le guen les craintes de certains
politiques et certains syndicats sur des
négociations dans les petites
entreprises qui serait déséquilibré
entre les salariés et les employeurs
selon vous ça c'est ça c'est factice en
tout cas ça se passe pas comme ça dans
les entreprises est ce que vous croyez
qu'elle est une entreprise normalement
constitué qui peut gérer une entreprise
alors que les salariés ne sont pas
d'accord il faut chercher à convaincre
il faut j'ai bien entendu qu'il y à une
négociation
donc il ya des plus il ya des mois il ya
des contraintes mais on avance tous dans
le même sens et donc le fait de pouvoir
instaurer ce dialogue
au contraire pour moi c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement fap au mois dé en
tant que chef d'entreprise en plus
d'ailleurs vous l'avez pas dit mais dans
le
they de nom de l'entreprise dans
lesquels je suis je suis également je
m'occupe de la digne paix puisque nous
sommes sous forme de dmp donc la dlp de
rappeler que ces délégations donc unique
du personnel 1 qui regroupe déjà un
petit peu ce qui est maintenant fixé par
l'ordonnancé pour toutes les entreprises
au dessus de 50 seuil de 50 salariés et
donc le dialogue est nécessaire enfin on
ne peut pas imaginer une entreprise dans
lequel il y ait des désaccords complet
entre les salariés et les employeurs
ça fonctionne pas alors derrière chris
est un lieu où on échange derrière
question a peut-être un peu naïve sur
ces ordonnances elles seront promulguées
par le par le président journal officiel
normalement vers le 25 septembre est ce
que ça veut dire que dès le mois
d'octobre le chômage va commencer à
baisser ce que c'était ça aussi la la
promesse était désormais 90 selon un peu
on va dire les souhaits du patronat pour
permettre l'embauché des cdd des
chômeurs et des sans emploi et nouveaux
arrivants il faut être très très clair
les faits ne sera pas immédiat c'est pas
vrai c'est un changement d'état d'esprit
sarah signal fort c'est un instauration
d'un dialogue social dans un esprit
différent
donc il faut du jeu de toute façon des
signaux forts pour commencer cela mais
bien entendu l'effet sur l'emploi ne
sera pas immédiat c'est il faut se
serait trompé que de dire cela
par contre ça doit effectivement
déclencher un nouvel état d'esprit et on
sait très bien que dans l'économie comme
dans les relations sociales
le côté psychologique est ressentie et
des chefs d'entreprise et des salariés
c'est primordial pour pouvoir redémarrer
alors encore qu'un rester avec nous on
passe tout de suite au reste de
l'actualité de la semaine
et décidément cette semaine le medef a
trusté les une de l'actualité avec la
traditionnelle université d'été du
syndicat patronal c'était à jouy en
josas mardi et mercredi 7500 chefs
d'entreprise étaient présents sur place
et notre journaliste également miquel et
demi d'euros reportage c'est une
tradition ici dans les yvelines depuis
19 ans le medef le principal syndicat
des patrons organise son université
d'été ici sur le campus hec paris à jour
josas mais concrètement à quoi ça sert à
informer a informé par les médias
puisque la presse vous êtes là la presse
est là ça donne le ton de ce que veut
faire le medef
et puis encore une fois je lis pour nous
à d'errance à peine de rencontrer
d'échanger autrement que dans nos
commissions autres n'ont vraiment plus
convivial
cette année sept mille cinq cents chefs
d'entreprise ont fait le déplacement
jusqu'aux yvelines pour assister à 12
conférences sur les thèmes de l'économie
de l'emploi et de la france des
rendez-vous qui ont permis aux
entrepreneurs de se réunir pendant 48
heures et les conférences qui sont
toujours intéressantes parce que l'idh
ouvert l'esprit ouvrir le cerveau pour
écouter effectivement ce qui se passe à
droite à gauche est toujours intéressant
surtout quand des choses sont dites
importantes comme tout à l'heure sur les
contractualisations du travail qui sont
des sujets qui sont effectivement durant
ce moment qu'ils sont importants
on voit là tous ces choses là sont
importantes à écouter il n'y avait pas
que des entrepreneurs la sphère
politique a également graviter autour de
cette manifestation neuf ministres se
sont rendus ici
un jour josas on peut noter également la
présence d'élus et binoy je tenais à
travailler avec le méné 78 j'avais pas
encore rencontré et on a passé une
partie de l'après midi ensemble un cas
semble d'entrepreneurs hier c'est
essentiel de créer une routine avec eux
une fois par trimestre on puisse se voir
et qu'on puisse challenge et les projets
du gouvernement les attendent sur le
terrain l'événement a également permis
aux syndicats ouvriers de se faire
entendre lors de ce deuxième jour de
l'université d'été du medef une
manifestation qui a réuni plus d'une
centaine de personnes a été organisée
nous avons rencontré un acteur local
ça fait plusieurs années qu'on le fait
cette année c'est un peu comme l'année
dernière on est dans le même contexte où
l'année dernière s'étaient la loi elle
comme ricky se préparait en cours d'été
là cette année c'est un peu particulier
puisque il ya là les ordonnances qui
sont en cours de rédaction sur la loi
travail prochain acte du rapport de
force entre les syndicats le patronat et
le gouvernement le 12 septembre prochain
avec la première grande manifestation
nationale contre la réforme du code du
travail
alors laurent courquin je me tourne vers
vous pour une dernière est simple
question sur sept on va dire un peu
partie polémiquer cette manifestation de
la cgt on l'a vu aussi pendant tout
l'été puis l'an passé avec la loi elle
conneries on al'impression véritablement
que vous êtes irréconciliables patronat
et syndicats aujourd'hui dans le monde
de l'entreprise
est-ce que ça c'est pour on va dire les
caméras les médias ou est-ce que c'est
aussi le cas dans le monde de
l'entreprise ou alors vous arrivez à
dialoguer avec les syndicats
d'accord très honnêtement qu'on arrive à
dialoguer wifi qui m'ont avec les
syndicats une entreprise bien entendu
parfois il peut y avoir des points de
blocage assez significatif mais on en
est on en n'est pas là dieu merci dans
les entreprises
donc non non il n'y a pas de revient
soit respect de dialogue
l'entreprise oui mais oui parce que tout
le monde à terre a effectivement bon
chacun négocie c'est normal ça fait
partie de guillemets du jeu il en
ressort effectivement quelque chose mais
non il n'y a pas cette opposition
systématique
il ya beaucoup plus de réalisme dans les
entreprises merci laurent qu'aucun
d'être venu en plateau et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes notamment le
vice-président du medef
soixante dix huit merci à vous la
préparation de la rentrée également dans
l'actualité de la semaine lundi trois
cent mille élèves sont attendus sur le
banc des écoles de l'académie de
versailles pour les professeurs
stagiaires cette nouvelle année scolaire
a déjà débuté lundi dernier ils étaient
tous réunis à l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
mélanie poker face aux recteurs
d'académie ce lundi 28 août de nouveaux
professeurs les lauréats du concours
2010 est cette année il serait
stagiaires c'est un sentiment partagé je
suis à la fois stressé très heureuse de
pouvoir concrètement devenir professeur
des écoles après une année de
préparation concours donc c'est vraiment
un moment très attendu rassurer donner
confiance aux 350 nouveaux enseignants
qui intègre l'académie
la journée est rythmée par des discours
et des ateliers
le concours 2017 est un excellent cru
avec une moyenne d épreuves supérieur à
14 sur l'ensemble de quatre épreuves
extrêmement exigeante et que cette
réussite au concours est sanctionné à
l'issue de cette année de stage leur
demander d'être audacieux d'expérimenter
et on a bien vu que il en était presque
surpris mais c'est bien ainsi que nous
avancerons parce qu'il n'ya pas une
façon d'enseigner à un ensemble d'élèves
l'académie accueille près de trois cent
mille élèves cette année pour ces jeunes
professeurs le vif du sujet comment ce
lundi 4 septembre à 8h30 et du côté des
élèves aussi certains travaillent déjà
la verrière douze collégiens ont
participé à un stage de remobilisation
scolaire cette semaine cours le matin et
sport l'après-midi une bonne manière de
faire quelques révisions après deux mois
de pause estivale et de reprendre en
douceur le rythme de l'école et l'après
midi on fait du sport parce que voilà si
une pré rentrée on n'est pas dans
l'intensif comme dans les cours on fait
quand même une petite partie un peu de
détente
le projet c'est surtout voilà de
commencer à la leur
allez réoccuper la journée et à les
occuper avec des activités que ça soit
scolaire ou sportif
enfin la région ile de france elle aussi
à préparer sa rentrée scolaire cette
semaine lundi la présidente de la région
valérie pécresse présidente les
républicains a exposé les grandes
nouveautés 2010 est pour moderniser les
lycées miquel et demi d'euros et les
arènes entrée dans l'ère du numérique
c'est la volonté première de la région
le haut débit qui couvrait seulement 38
% des lycées en 2015 en couvre cette
année 58 % l'objectif à terme est de
s'étendre d'ici 2020 à 100 % des
établissements afin de combler les
disparités entre paris et la banlieue
toujours plus connecté les professeurs
et lycéens vont avoir l'occasion de
découvrir la nouvelle plateforme
collaborative mon lycée point net
et l'idée c'est d'avoir une plate forme
de réunions open source qui permettent à
tous les professeurs d'échanger entre
eux mais entre lycées à tous les élèves
d'échanger avec les professeurs aux
élèves de travailler entre eux adoptée
par 270 lycée cette année mon lycée
point net promet d'être plus adaptée et
efficace que le dispositif lily mise en
place en 2009 en fait il est vraiment
centré sur les usages et en l'usagé
c'est qui pour nous c'est les
professeurs et les lycéens
essentiellement donc une grande
simplicité la possibilité de créer sur
sa propre interface c'est à dire de
personnaliser son portail on s'est
vraiment appuyé sur les modèles des
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui le suivi
quotidien des lycées va lui aussi être
informatisé puisque les établissements
se verront remettre un carnet de santé
en ligne avec toutes les informations
sur le lycée qui seront transmises
directement la région pour permettre la
maintenance plus facile pour permettre
les travaux les réparations les
rénovations à travers ces différentes
initiatives
la région espère contribuer à la lutte
contre le décrochage scolaire qui touche
25 mille jeunes franciliens
chaque année le tourisme à à la hausse
cet été 2010 était pour le moment une
belle année pour le secteur notamment en
ile de france plus 10,2 pour cent de
fréquentation au premier semestre dans
la région et les yvelines ont profité de
cette affluence poule plus de 3,6
millions de visiteurs se sont notamment
rendus à versailles cet été certains
établissements ont réalisé leur
meilleure saison depuis 15 ans le bilan
dans le département avec camille lambert
nul besoin de partir très loin de paris
pour faire le tour de la france nombreux
l'ont bien compris
tour eiffel ou mont saint-michel 194
milles visiteurs sont venus découvrir
france miniature à elancourt
un chiffre important pour le parc qui
enregistre sa meilleure saison depuis 15
ans grâce à quelques nouveautés fort
boyard est un a été un déclencheur de
visites évident parce qu'il répond à la
demande de nos visiteurs 80 % de
victoires sont des familles évidemment
le jeune public est friand de cette
émission est de pouvoir interagir avec
avec les personnages due forme
et puis on a agrémenté le parc ces
dernières années 2
vos animations pour apporter
l'interactivité au circuit de visite et
ça contribue à la revisite ça donne
envie de revivre cette expérience à
versailles également le bilan s'avère
positif 24 % de visiteurs en plus au
château par rapport à 2016 autre domaine
tout autant satisfait le château de
breteuil
ici aussi l'année a été très concluante
nous avons enregistré une hausse
une hausse de la fréquentation d'à peu
près 10% ce qui pour nous est très bon
puisqu'on doit être à peu près dix mille
personnes de plus pour l'ensemble de la
saison jusqu'au 31 juillet pour nous ne
peut être la meilleure saison qu'on ait
pu avoir dans les années récentes
de bons résultats qui s'expliquent à
breteuil par les nombreux événements
mise en place en juin juillet et août
mais c'est bien l'ensemble des yvelines
qui a bénéficié de cette reprise après
une année 2016 morose en raison des
attentats de paris et de nice 6 8 % de
fréquentation en plus au premier
semestre 2010 est le déploiement de
volontaires du tourisme notamment à
versailles a contribué à cette
augmentation
500 volontaires avaient été mobilisés
dans toute l'île de france pour informer
les touristes en politique mardi la
ville de cheuvreux a rendu un dernier
hommage à son maire claude genot l'édile
est décédé le 22 août dernier à l'âge de
74 ans des suites d'une longue maladie
ses obsèques ont eu lieu à l'église
saint-martin de chevreuse plusieurs
centaines d'habitants et des
personnalités politiques locales ont
fait le déplacement on écoute l'un de
ses adjoints claude avait mis tout son
espoir de ce dernier banda là pour la
création d'une crèche qui va être
réalisé et la création d'une association
les maisons des associations dont il
était très fier malheureusement il ne
verra pas achevée mais elle est déjà
bien bien commencé claude cet été un
homme de courage parce que tu es son
médecin traitant et il a lutté contre la
maladie là il a assumé ses fonctions
jusqu'à
jusqu'à ses dernières forces politiques
toujours et rameau maintenant des
élections sénatoriales qui sont
organisées le dimanche 24 septembre dans
les yvelines les six postes de sénateurs
sont en jeu et les parties dévoile
progressivement leur liste c'est le cas
notamment des républicains le président
du sénat gérard larcher sera une
nouvelle fois tête de liste pour les
républicains une liste dans laquelle se
retrouve en cinquième position le
président de saint quentin en yvelines
michel laugier la droite qui dispose
actuellement de quatre sénateurs dans
les yvelines feront face fera face
notamment à la liste dissidente du maire
de maisons laffitte jacques milliards au
centre le modem éludé y feront liste
commune pour ces élections en revanche
pas d'accord avec la république en
marche qui espère remporter des sièges
le mouvement fondé par emmanuel macron
sera menée par martin lévriers
conseiller municipal à versailles enfin
à gauche eddie ait se présentera pour le
parti radical de gauche le parti
socialiste avec sandrine quand vous le
voyez à l'écran ce n'a pas encore
communiqué les noms de ces candidats
enfin les élus communistes du
département appelle dans un communiqué à
un large rassemblement pour élire au
moins un sénateur de gauche dans les
yvelines
les listes définitives seront connues le
8 septembre prochain
on referme cette première émission de la
saison avec une idée de sortie
découverte à magny les hameaux l'église
du village saint germain de paris est
ouverte au public à partir de ce
week-end et ce pour tout le mois de
septembre
l'occasion de découvrir ou redécouvrir
cette église classée depuis quelques
mois
monument historique la rédaction de tv
60,18 vous présentait déjà en février le
lieu reportage de camille lambert
[Musique]
cet hôtel est absolument exceptionnel
parce que vous n'avez pas d'équivalent
et de dire pour le nord le nord au nord
de la loire
généralement au 17e c'est plutôt des
hôtels avec des peintures ici on a un
hôtel de stuc
les villageois ont gardé l'hôtel tel
qu'il était à la fin du xviie siècle il
n'ya plus d'équivalent dans les églises
de l'île de france aujourd'hui
cet hôtel c'est l'un des joyaux de
l'église saint germain de paris qui lui
a valu son inscription au titre de
monument historique
une reconnaissance pour cet édifice du
12e siècle
magny les hameaux havrais de 2002 à 2009
pour sa restauration coût total des
travaux 950 mille euros financé à 80 %
par la ville
[Musique]
beaucoup d'habitants tenait à ce que ce
ce lieu cette église soit préservée et
puis effectivement qu'on puisse avoir
une histoire la grande histoire de
port-royal d'échangés de magny les
hameaux côte à côte ont obtenu en
novembre cette distinction permettra de
conserver au mieux la mémoire locale ce
qui fait l'immense richesse de l'église
aujourd'hui à manille c'est qu'elle
conserve une quarantaine de pierres
tombales c'est la plus grosse collection
de tout le nord de la loire dont 40
pierre tombale entre le xiiie siècle et
le xviie siècle dont les deux tiers
proviennent de l'abbaye de port royal
autre découverte ce tableau du xviie
siècle du peintre italien guido reni
saint jérôme au désert une seule
réplique existe à la national gallery de
londres
l'église du village n'a pas fini de
dévoiler tous ses secrets
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo avant
de vous quitter je vous rappelle que le
retour de l'information quotidienne aura
lieu lundi sur l'antenne de tv2 60,18
vous retrouverez notamment votre journal
local tous les jours à 18h avec grégory
canal et d'ici là bon week-end à tous et
à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]